if you have an extra room or Suite in
your home please consider hosting a
family you might remember this one this
is 6 months ago in Massachusetts when
the government of Massachusetts look at
this they are literally telling people
to give up rooms in their houses to
illegals most importantly if you have an
extra room or Suite in your home please
consider hosting a family safe housing
and shelter is our most pressing need
become a spor family you can contact the
Brazilian Worker Center for more
information on how you can step up if
you're willing to have an additional
family be part of your family if you're
a local official a college President a
business owner or a faith leader with an
available building or space in your
community please work with us to offer
it as a shelter site if you're a social
service provider please consider
becoming an emergency assistant homeless
shelter provider our resources are
stretched thin there as well and if
you're a hotel or a motel owner consider
opening it up for emergency assistance
if you're a landlord or a property owner
we can use you too can connect you with
service providers to help transition
families into permanent housing everyone
has something they can offer what an
endless bunch of BS ironically you
people don't have anything you can offer
your your government Stooges who uh have
wrecked the border and then you want
people to give the empty rooms in their
houses to a bunch of people that we have
no idea what they believe you want
landlords to not make money but just to
let people take over you want churches
to give up like this is what an
absolutely
dysfunctional really communist
craptastic government would offer and
it's happening in all of uh the blue
States and blue
cities